as 1991 was reaching its end the Soviet
Union the world's second superpower was
in the process of catastrophic political
collapse this outcome had been fairly
apparent for over a year now and the
Soviet President Mikhail Gorbachev had
tried numerous policies to preserve the
USSR these included widespread reforms
notably glasnost which opened up the
press allowing for criticism of the
government and perestroika which
reformed the internal operations of the
USSR notably by instigating economic
reforms which allowed private enterprise
and foreign investment something which
upset many hardline communists whilst
the collapse of communism there was by
late 1990 seen is mostly inevitable the
collapse of the state itself wasn't so
certain in early 1991 as part of
Gorbachev democratic reforms there was a
referendum on whether or not the USSR
should be preserved which was approved
by over three-quarters of the people
from these areas the other areas had to
use a technical historical term noped
out and didn't take part now when I say
that people voted to preserve the USSR I
don't mean the Union of Soviet Socialist
Republics but a new state the Union of
Soviet sovereign republics which as the
name suggests didn't have to be
communist furthermore a new post was
created within the USSR the President of
the Russian Soviet Federative Socialist
Republic and in July Boris Yeltsin was
elected to that post something which
upset many hardline communists and so
some high-ranking members of the
Communist Party including Vice President
gennady and ivan head of the KGB
vladimir krutov decided to intervene in
August of 1991 while Gorbachev was on
holiday in Crimea the plotters let's
into action and placed him under house
arrest he was asked to resign but he
promptly told them no one so they told
the country he was seriously ill and
unable to lead and in response to this
the plotters created the State Committee
on the emergency situation led by a
naive as acting president which would
run the country in the meantime the
Soviet coup had formally begun the coup
began with tanks roaring into Moscow and
politicians who were seen as the threat
being quickly arrested with one notable
exception Boris Yeltsin the committee
quickly shut down all critical
newspapers and broadcasted what they
were going to do they were going to fix
the economy restore the Communist Party
to its rightful place take back control
of the parts of the country that wanted
to break away and finally win the Cold
War sounds lovely yet despite this
rhetoric the people running the country
didn't have
plans on how to do this except for stop
the reforms this new leadership was
incredibly worrying to the wider Soviet
citizenry and was especially so to the
press in anyone who is criticized
communism recently since there was an
expectation that the new leaders would
begin a purge once they cemented their
position an expectation that wasn't
entirely without merit since most of the
KGB were on boards also the coup had
some support from the military including
the defense minister Dmitry as off hence
the tanks on the streets not all of the
military was supported though notably
the higher-ups in the air force were
opposed and there was a severe rift
across the Armed Forces military support
for the coup didn't stop Soviet citizens
from protesting against the change in
leadership and Yeltsin was a notable
critic who became a central opponent who
called for Gorbachev's restoration he
was also supported by a sizeable part of
the Soviet Army who together with some
civilians formed a barricade outside the
White House not that one
in Lithuania which had declared
independence the year before Soviet
troops were still stationed there in the
committee plan for its reintegration
into the USSR across the USSR widespread
protests and strikes broke out as many
politicians both communists did not
oppose the committee's actions
furthermore Western leaders condemned
the coup and halted all cooperation with
the USSR within the Soviet Union the
individual republics were split down
these lines and the committee wasn't
without some support internationally
communist states like Cuba North Korea
and China was supportive of the coup
since they felt that you naive and his
colleagues were right and they had no
interest whatsoever in losing the
primary defender of global communism
things started to heat up as
demonstrations became more incensed than
there were some isolated incidents of
violence this was also the point where
some in the committee realized that they
weren't going to be successful the day
was also rounded out by Estonia
unilaterally declaring independence
which probably wasn't what the coup
leaders were hoping for overnight there
was some fighting between soldiers on
the side of the committee in those who
had sided with Yeltsin with the out
since troops were standing the assault
it was at this point that the rest of
the committee realized that they had
failed and some of them subsequently
fled Moscow you now have opted to face
his fate in Moscow whereas the rest
barring one because well went to see
Gorbachev in Crimea in order to
hopefully not get purged once he was
back in charge the members of the
military which had sided with the
committee then switched allegiance
pulled all military forces out of Moscow
the Supreme Soviet the Soviet Parliament
then announced that the crisis was over
and that Gorbachev was restored as
president the coup was over the
remaining committee members were quickly
rounded up and arrested and order was
restored to the streets of Moscow there
were several reasons for the cooze
failure
the first was corbett ross refusal to
resign which robbed Jenai EV of any
legitimacy in the eyes of the public
another was that the military wasn't
entirely on board and politicians like
Yeltsin kicked up a fuss yet the biggest
reason that the coup failed was the
people who took to the streets and
stared down armed soldiers to prevent a
return to the politics of old
Gorbachev's changes were popular and the
cooze leaders assumed that taking
control of the party meant that they
could stop them yet where they
miscalculated was that the party was no
longer able to override the people and
their support for the changes the coup
effectively doomed the Soviet Union and
the Communist Party there and the USSR
itself would only last for another four
months the leaders of the committee were
imprisoned and Yeltsin would go on to
become Russia's first president the
last-ditch attempt to preserve the
Soviet system was a failure in the fact
that they didn't spiral into a wider
revolutionary conflict is honestly quite
amazing I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with the
special thanks to my patrons James
Bissonnette John lucid a man of culture
Danny Maloney little holiday John biz
gas Rob Waterhouse Mo James Castaneda
Aaron the white Jordan Longley Gustav
Swan marcus asana rashid ali spinning
three plates filled oink oink david
silverman maggie packs Kowski spencer
Lightfoot Lexie Schwinn Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappell Marvin Castle Winston Hayward
and Izzy I mean really probably just the
worst attempt at a coup ever